Alright. Let's take out the words that accurately fill
on this concept map. Here in lesson four we
learned that the human genome can be divided between
the non-coding DNA and the protein coding DNA. The
non-coding DNA represents about 98% of our genome whereas
protein coding DNA represents about 2%. No matter how
you divide it you've got two copies of the
human genome in every cell. Now non coding DNA includes
three main types of non coding sequence
that we discussed. One type was a promoter.
Another type was an enhancer. Now enhancers are
bound by activators. So that's how we knew
enhancers went here instead of here. You know
that if promoters and enhancers are two of
the types, then the third type are silencers.
Silencers are bound by repressors and activators and
repressors are types of transcription factors.
Transcription factors specifically bind around the
TATA sequence. Which is essential to drive initiation of transcription via the
promoter. So everything in this lesson
really centers around the promoter sequence.
Because the promoter is the main
effective non-coding DNA region that regulates transcription
of a protein coding gene. Now, transcription
factors generally are proteins that bind any regulatory
region of DNA. Activators and repressors are
very specific types that bind certain regions like
enhancers that promote transcription initiation via promoters
and repressors that bind silencers which silence or
inhibit Transcription from a promoter region. But no
matter what promoters sit in front of protein
coding genes, which are essentially the divisions
of protein coding DNA here. Now our
transcription factors that bind regulatory regions of
DNA thus regulate the expression of protein
coding DNA. Or genes. We also learn very specifically that, just like in lesson
three, that different sequences of protein coding
DNA can be called alleles. The same
is true for non coding DNA. We can
have different sequences called alleles, and these all
originate from mutations which we'll learn about more
in lesson six. Overall, In the human genome
both protein-coding DNA, even though it represents only
about 2% or less, or non-coding DNA, which
represents the vast majority of our genome, they
work together to specify thousands of different cell types.
And together these are organized by the process of development that makes
us Who we are, all of our complexity, all of our traits.